some sort of legal defense inside the
courtroom and that's what steve bannon
knows here is that he can go outside and
yell and scream and say this stupid [ __ ]
and the judge really is going to pay too
much attention to it in the courtroom
because it's just fodder on tv um
especially if he has a good legal
defense but the the problem is the
problem is like with donald trump is the
[ __ ] says this [ __ ] in court
like he's writing his own motions and
crown and [ __ ] and he's really
he's really pissed off this morning i
mean he is
he is upset at the [ __ ] lincoln
project like dude is big mad
at the lincoln project for dropping
truth
on his supporters via fox news uh here
is the
uh the post on fraud social
um if you want to
let me let me remove this banner here so
you can kind of read it here the
perverts and low lives
i don't know why that's capitalized
again yeah i don't know what the [ __ ]
also why was that the voice you went to
like the perverts and low lives well i
mean that sometimes when i read trump's
statements this is the voice that i read
it in because this is kind of who he's
talking to my friend this is the
people's that's he's not talking to me
well no he's not talking to us he's
talking to [ __ ] boneheads out there
that again have been mind [ __ ] as jim
put it on
on this website and others like facebook
the perverts and low lives
of the lincoln project are back on where
else fox news i don't know why he why
why does he add words where he doesn't
need it i do this every once in a while
he loves the commas i'll add words where
i don't need them and and sometimes when
i read my tweets before i tweet push the
tweet button because very rarely do i i
don't know if anyone notices that like
when i tweet i write it out and i push
tweet i don't re go back and read the
[ __ ]
i push tweet i'm tweeting so i push
tweet but he adds words here
you're so you're saying ads words just
so he can have commas is what you're
saying well i think you know a lot of it
he might suffer from the same thing you
do which is just like you it's a stream
of consciousness hey easy do you know
i'm putting me in the same way i'm not
saying that you're the same person oh
okay i'm just saying that you have a
similar way like you were like yeah this
dumb mother like you'll be like this
dumb m effort and then you'll have like
the two red exclamation points yeah and
you'll just like quote tweet yeah i know
i know tony's is what his tweets are
like uh yeah but it is very much like
yeah you'll be like yeah [ __ ] and then
you'll send it to me and he's like ooh
am i gonna get banned for this yeah
every once in a while i'll actually type
out a tweet and before i hit tweet i
will screenshot it in the draft
send it to game and go hey you think
i'll get banned and you're like yeah
definitely i'm like sweet i'm tweeting
that [ __ ] like that
if you're saying yes i will get banned
that is something you're going to get
you're going to get to a certain point
where your account is reaching enough
people and someone is going to then be
like i am so upset by this tweet and
then you'll buy my two red exclamation
points how offensive
i mean according to republicans those
exclamation points are the devil well
they are red um he goes on grandpa
poopypants goes on to say here i thought
they ran away to an asylum after their
last catastrophic campaign with charges
made against them that were big time
sleaze as if he's never had big time
sleaze allegations against him epstein
taking teenagers to mar-a-lago for him
personally i'm just saying and me
getting many millions more votes in 2020
than i got in 2016. okay there was
higher turnout so yeah that's true but
you lost by 8 million [ __ ] yeah
and then he goes on to say i'm not sure
who paul ryan runyon
[Music]
is he saying paul ryan he's saying paul
ryan but he spelled paul ryan
and i don't know if it was is that a new
name
i don't know this is what's very
confusing about it well now i now i'm
wondering is this a real person
no or
no because he says run fox only has high
standards for him okay i don't know why
he put quotes around trump i'm not sure
um for trump ads
but not for anyone else i i don't know
exactly what this sentence is saying i'm
not really sure i'm not really sure all
ryan run fox only has high standards
the paul
ryan
right run fox maybe
because paul ryan is on the board of fox
news
yeah yeah he's on oh okay okay got it
okay well i would have probably put like
dashes or hyphens between this connected
this is the paul ryan run fox news only
has high standards for trump ads but not
for anyone else got it okay so he's
saying that any ads okay now i got a
transition
i had to read this a few times to really
get it okay so he's saying that anything
that's related to trump anything about
the big lie mike lindell all of that
[ __ ] spreading just misinformation
about the election and trump losing
or trump winning rather
they won't play them but they'll play
every other single ad they don't have a
they don't have a standard for anything
else just for anything well of course
because they don't want to get [ __ ]
sued they're already in a [ __ ]
lawsuit with dominion software which is
crazy because they have mike lindell my
pillow commercials all over fox again
oh they haven't back on fox yeah oh yeah
oh yeah but uh but it says it goes he
goes on to
to puke out of his pie hole here um the
perverts again capitalize perverts i
don't know why he's capitalizing
perverts here it seems weird um he seems
to have an affection for perverts should
not be allowed to quote false advertise
again the air quote thing not
i don't
i don't understand
why he's putting air quotes on something
that he thinks is true
anyways um false advertised comma and
fox news should not allow it to happen
and then he says
see you in court
three examination points why is court
capitalized here i don't know why
i have no idea i mean like here i know
how to write these things i don't know
why he does them right so i like i know
what word should be capitalized what
word should be in all caps you know what
what uh
you know
uh buzzword should be used can i explain
why he does those things no i can't but
i can imitate them
well you sent me a tweet here is this
this is um is this rick wilson this is
rick wilson responding to trump's uh
whiny whining
this is not fair
oh no i'm sure rick has a uh well if you
went back well okay
we'll play we'll play that we're going
to play the ad i'm going to play it
we're playing the sequence of events out
of order but that's fine hey what the
[ __ ] man i'm playing them in the exact
order i want to play them in
we're going to get to the ad here i'm
trying to hang the audience here on this
ad this is anticipation okay
anticipation here's rick's because he
didn't just tweet he made a [ __ ]
video
um that's you know that's showing
commitment rick says donald trump is
truthing again this is how you actually
use
error quotes but you know
and who's counting so
one on rick he knows how to use air
quotes um
most people do donald trump is truthing
that he's going to sue the lincoln
project uh i have words for him oh i
can't i can't wait i would imagine that
rick is gonna challenge him here
um but
let's let's see what says you rick hey
folks wanted to say hi really quickly
and to just give donald trump a message
since you threatened to sue the lincoln
project this morning
go for it
go for it [ __ ]
come at me
i can't wait we're we're delighted by
the thought that you would try to sue us
donald do it
do it
i double dog dare you you know when we
put up the billboards in times square of
jared and ivanka during the covet crisis
at the end of the 2020 campaign we
received this letter from mark castle
with donald trump's attorney and it was
this complete you know blustering [ __ ]
show oh we will
sue you we read it in the bane voice
right
you're not gonna sue anybody donald
you're not gonna do [ __ ] you're not
gonna do a god damn thing you were weak
you were impotent you were flabby you
were sitting there in the bridal suite
at mar-a-lago or in the bridal suite at
bedminster grinding your gears wondering
why that
the lincoln project no matter how many
times you tried to kill us keeps coming
at you you know why
we're here
in this fight for the long haul because
you are a threat to democracy you are a
threat to america you are a threat to
the republic you are a threat to the
constitution you are a thief of
classified documents you are a traitor
to this country you've tried to
overthrow this government and the system
of our
peaceful transition of power and [ __ ]
you
we're here you're not we will keep
kicking your ass every single day so if
you want to try to sue us donald go for
it throw down let's go we can't wait you
won't do it because you are in fact as i
said previously completely impotent just
ask melania
anyway folks other than that it's a
great day for america steve bannon is in
looking at the inside of a jail cell
once again donald trump is raging in
mara go [ __ ] yourself or a bedminster
wherever he is today and uh
it's a good day to be in the fight talk
to you soon oh
rick come on the show [ __ ] here is the
ad that rick wilson is talking about in
that video that donald trump is so
[ __ ] pissed off about and when i show
this there's a reason why i showed this
in this order when i show this you'll
understand why the word salad from
donald trump and why the great clap back
from rick wilson let's watch
dear maga
we have some bad news
no not that he lost not that your little
coup attempt failed and its planners and
the attackers are going to jail
no
the really bad news is why trump told
you he lost
why he set it up way before the 2020
election
it wasn't voter fraud but it was fraud
trump told you the election was stolen
to rip you off to sucker you to take
your hard-earned money and shovel it
into his pockets
he spent it on himself not to take back
the white house it was the biggest scam
in political history
every dollar you sent him paid to keep
his shaky business empire and lavish
lifestyle going it was a sucker's game
all along and you know who the sucker is
it's you
bitching
and i don't know why he's so upset they
really didn't target him i think he's
upset because it may piss off a lot of
his supporters
i mean i think that's yeah yeah yeah
that's what he's really pissed off about
it's
it's the fact that
because
they attack
his supporters right and his supporters
and everything they believe in is so
ingrained within trump and what he says
then
uh
it's an attack on him right he's like
you're attacking the people that that
pay me you're attacking my piggy bank
right you're attacking the people who
push my lies
ergo you are attacking me right there's
like this transit of property if you
attack them and they support me then
you're attacking me right
and it's
well it's the same thing that that uh
these morons have been saying that that
they're coming and it's steve bannon put
that out in a statement we read it
yesterday is they're not just coming
after me and president trump it's all of
us that they're
they are they yeah right i mean we
talked about this like they gave me the
virus it's like no who is they nobody
gave you [ __ ] man you did it to yourself
you exposed yourself
you got too greedy you flew too close to
the sun your [ __ ] wings burned up and
you flew and you and you fell back down
to earth right and now who's waiting but
merrick garland and the rest of his
[ __ ] merry band of prosecutors
they're coming after you and you're
[ __ ] worried and everyone else is
merrick garland robin hood is that what
you're i think mayor i think merrick
garland is robin hood
i would be very curious to see and i'm
sure i'll like you know upset some
people
uh but i would love to like put a
collection of people who are like
merrick garland isn't doing his job
merrick garland is an actor and we've
said it on the show multiple times for
months we said there's a reason why it's
taking long because
just this case just investigating trump
for mar-a-lago is a very timed well
time sensitive but it's a very tight
locked [ __ ] nobody knew about anything
until trump was like they raided my
house no one would have probably known
about any more of this until maybe he
found out i was committing crime right
but at the same time like oh [ __ ]
they're investigating bannon they're
investigating trump for uh you know the
super pac they're investigating him for
jan six they're investigating him for
mar-a-lago and taking the documents
they're investigating all these other
people that are committing fraud either
they're they're investigating the police
officers who who killed brianna taylor
all of these things at the same time
everyone's like oh you're not working
fast enough
they are
a multi-faceted group who are
multitasking
and doing a very good job of not
exposing or leaking these things before
a search warrant is done or an
investigation has begun or when you find
out it's like oh yeah we already sequel
we already brought together a grand jury
so this [ __ ] is moving
and so
i'd be curious to see all the people or
all the posts online people who were
just very upset at the time to be like
he's not working fast enough he's not
doing this he's like dude there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on it's not just about
trump there's a lot of justice to be
served in this country and i think
that's why lincoln project made that
[ __ ] ad